[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here
welcome back to dope tech i'm your host
marquez brownlee
dope tech videos used to have a theme
yes
does this video have any sort of theme
at all absolutely not this is
three completely unrelated items they
have nothing to do with each other
and i'm going to take that as sort of a
challenge to make
the best segues between each of them
like a linus inspired game of high-tech
chain reaction
so let's begin okay so i tweeted a
picture of these
not too long ago and a lot of you had
questions understandably
what is going on with these hilariously
huge airpods so
these are the three x pods and i don't
know why they call them 3x because
they're clearly a lot bigger than three
times the size of airpods but they are
bluetooth speakers modeled after airpods
pro
there are the size of uh a camera and a
lens maybe
or like a really big coffee mug the
point is they're hilariously big
and weirdly enough even though they
definitely don't go in your ears even if
you are shack's size
they still have rubber tips so that if
you wanted to
if you wanted to put them in an
elephant's ears or something they would
have
a somewhat comfortable fit i guess so a
couple things you may be wondering about
them
one yes there is a black and a white
version
they do pair quickly and easily via
bluetooth
and on that stem you can see there's a
couple controls a power switch
some playback controls a microphone
and sadly a micro usb charging port and
you can also play music from these
from built-in fm radio a usb flash drive
or a tf card yeah
i have to look that up too it's a called
a trans flash card which is basically
the same thing
as microsd and they sound
like you're not buying these for how
they sound
come on these if you are wondering they
sound pretty bad actually they have
very very little bass they don't get
very loud um
maybe they are kind of sounding like
giant airpods there are other speakers
of this size that cost around the same
amount that get twice as loud
and sound much better you're not getting
these for the sound but really this is
much more about the novelty factor i
mean
look at them how is this not an amazing
conversation starter just sitting on a
shelf
in your living room you pick these up
they're super lightweight and then just
the fact that they actually function as
speakers
and all the sound comes from where you'd
expect them to is pretty sweet now i
just want you to know before you go out
and
buy these they are 40 bucks right now
on their site so i guess i should expect
this but they are
super cheaply built and you can feel it
immediately you can tell
uh it says on their site that they are
3d printed but i don't really know if i
believe that
there are seams all over the thing there
are screws
the grilles that match the metal on the
airpods are just
stickers but even if they are 3d printed
it doesn't seem to help the actual build
quality so don't buy these
for the build quality don't buy these
for the sound quality
buy these for the immense
flex that not only do you have airpods
pro but now you also have
the gigantic 50 times size airpods pros
they actually function
which is wild although minus the noise
cancellation actually what's funny is
when they ship these
you get a black and white but they're
both left airpods
but what they should have done what they
should do is give you one right
one left and then have them pair up in
stereo mode and let you really
get into it but maybe they'll save that
for the second gen
version speaking of the second gen
version
this is the second gen asus
zephyrus duo okay so you might remember
we already had a dual screen asus
laptop in a dope tech video less than a
year ago
that was the first gen one and i think
we can agree the main
complaint about that first version was
that screen up against the keyboard was
kind of hard to see it was a little off
axis and that's hard for any display
and then light would reflect off of it
and you know it was a matte finish and
everything but
that was the problem with it so boom
problem solved so this is basically a
sequel and you can see they've built
this
actually pretty simple hinge that every
time you open the laptop the second
screen also rises up
out of the laptop and tilts towards you
a bit for improved
visibility and it works and it's a
sturdy hinge too so since it's still a
4k touch screen
still has a matte finish it just is that
much more likely that you'll actually
use it now that you can actually see it
more
and you don't have to strain your neck
to look down at that screen so it's
smart design and it also has now this
bonus of a little bit of air can flow
through the back there
for cooling which is nice and there's
also the speakers down there and then
yeah all the same stuff
that i said about that first one about
how awesome it is to have a dual screen
computer
that of course applies to this one again
too it's like the touch bar
on steroids all the multitasking
capabilities
but also keep in mind there are still
all the weird quirks that come from this
unconventional form factor too
like the fact that there's no palm rest
built into the laptop from the keyboard
being pushed so far down
like the tiny mouse pad if you actually
use it without a mouse
now the power plug is also kind of in a
weird place in the middle of the left
hand side which i thought was curious
and the battery life also still takes a
hit since obviously you're powering
two 4k screens now instead of one it is
a 90 watt hour battery but you'll notice
the battery depleting much more quickly
if you have brightness up on both
screens like i usually do but hey
i'm happy to see asus really doubling
down on this
concept that was already pretty sweet in
the first version
and really working to improve it and
this new laptop also has great specs
it's an unlocked 8-core cpu it has
an rtx 2080 super max q 32 gigs of ram
solid-state storage it's definitely a
capable machine and they're not shy
about what it is capable of but
i think the coolest part is that asus is
listening
and is making stuff like this and i
think possibly the most telling part
about how they expect you to use this
laptop is in the ports layout so like i
said power plug is on the left hand side
that's along with
the mic and headphone jacks two
full-size usb
and one usb type-c on the right-hand
side
and then in the middle of the back
there's usb
ethernet and hdmi which is pretty
perfect if you're going to use it as a
desktop replacement
that's the type of stuff you'd run down
the back your desk while attaching the
whole thing to
a monitor which boom brings us to our
third
and final item that was smooth this is
the samsung odyssey g9 49-inch
ultra wide gaming monitor this thing is
ridiculous in so many ways
so everything about this monitor is to
the limits
okay first of all it comes in this box
this insane box
and then it's a 49-inch diagonal monitor
so
biggest monitor i've ever used and then
it's at a 5120 by 1440 resolution
so 5k wide which doesn't make it the
first monitor of that resolution but
i do believe this is the first one we've
seen at a 240hz refresh rate
with hdr 1000 certification thanks to
qled
so it gets crazy bright if you need it
to it has a one millisecond response
time
it supports nvidia g-sync over
displayport 1.4
and it's curved massively curved so
curved monitors there's different levels
of
the amount of curve you can have this
monitor is what's called a
1000 radius curve which just means
basically if you put
these monitors into a circle until they
all connected
the radius of that circle would be a
thousand centimeters
which without any context doesn't really
mean anything but what they're trying to
tell you with that number is it is very
very curved around that center point
and so it sticks out a lot from the base
as a result apparently the curve matches
the human eye
the bottom line is the experience you
get sitting in front of this thing
right in the middle right up close using
it and especially gaming on it
is one of maximum immersion i've never
had a monitor
get into my peripheral so much and then
it checks most of the rest of the other
boxes from a high-end monitor there's
two display port
one hdmi and a usb hub and audio jack
around the back there displayport is
definitely the best way to
get the most out of this monitor i also
kind of wish there was usb type-c
samsung as long as we're trying to check
all the boxes but it doesn't have that
and then also around the glossy white
back you can
turn on the rgb lights in the middle and
this thing glows
it's pretty sick it's it's kind of like
this infinity void
even though you never have to really
look at the back of your monitor
at least you know it's there and hey
maybe you get a little spill over onto
the wall behind it
but what's actually nice about this back
besides the cable management
is this headphone holder because even
though it is kind of hard to reach
behind a huge monitor like this
it's nice that they thought about that
and put something back there because
when you have this monitor on your desk
it's really hard to have
anything else on your desk so that is
the price you pay for this huge
vast expanse of a screen but hey a lot
of people looking at this right now are
thinking
you know what that's worth it i want
this so if you are one of those people
who literally wants to buy this
along with anything else mentioned in
this dope tech below the like button
i'll leave all the links to everything
this you'll find is 700 bucks
which is definitely expensive for a
monitor
costs more than the equivalent of like
buying
two separate 27 inch 240 hertz monitors
but i mean the bad ass factor of having
it all in one unit
the lack of a bezel in the middle the
hdr certification the q led
the image ah the curve
it's kind of hard to to match this now
for me personally like i've gamed on
this a bit
i'm i've never been a huge ultra wide
person i need the vertical pixels when
most of the work i'm doing requires
vertical scrolling so
ultra wides are ultra wide they've never
really been very tall so 1440p
not enough pixels vertically for me but
for gaming
i mean this thing is incredible and
that's why it's dope tech so that
is the samsung odyssey g9 this has been
dope tech i hope the segways were up to
par for at least what i
set the expectations to be at the
beginning of this video
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one peace